whoa guys we got ourselves a matrix
resurrections official trailer two last
week was a deja vu trailer all these
titles in the movie each other such as
saying trailer too it took me like a
little while after uploading me like i
don't think there's a real trailer tip
this
is
i wanted to mention a couple things
really fast i got a special vid in the
works right now i can't say much about
it but it involves the matrix cast
that's all i'll say uh
yeah
secondly the putting the matrix out on
imax for a temporary release you guys
should go check it out man nature's my
favorite movie of all time tied with t2
judgment day i obviously love a certain
kind of genre let's see what's going on
and then talk about it afterwards
[Music]
we can't see it
but we're all trapped inside these
strange repeating boobs room 101 yeah
billions of people just living out their
lives
oblivious well that's a clue yeah
but this is the moment
for you to show us what is real
i remember this
damn right
it's the construct
so deja vu
and yet it's obviously all wrong
maybe this isn't the story we think it
is
they taught you good
made you believe their world was all you
deserved
but some part of you knew that was a lie
some part of you remembered what was
real it's so easy to forget how much
noise the matrix pumps into your head
wow
something else makes the same kind of
noise
whoa
war
yeah
jps
what happens to nia
mr
it's my turn to believe in her
part of me feels like i have been
waiting my whole life for you
yes
if you want to see twitter you can
chills everywhere right now
oh
wow
my dream ended here
oh no
yeah i think my theory is right there i
said last video
yeah
yeah
of course you do
can't forget that
we're gonna have it escalate into this
like doom and gloom vibe and stakes and
then cap it off with a this is still as
badass
love that trailers oh my god i got
thoughts yeah i don't know if you guys
caught my reaction to the deja vu
trailer but basically the theory that i
was coming up with with combing the
footage like the two ones were linked to
trinity and jonathan groff's character i
mean a lot of us were kind of thinking
that he might be some rendition of agent
smith the way they edit this especially
seems to be like no he's agent smith
resurrected i still feel like he's not
exactly that i'm wondering if he has
more control over the situation than
what the trailer is letting on because
in the first matrix movie this this
trailer flat out says it's deja vu we're
in a loop and a lot of it's harkening
back especially to the first matrix
movie however they also have the line of
it might not be exactly what we think it
is and there's something along the lines
of what we've seen with if you combine
all the footage we've got of jonathan
groff this seems like a lot of what
we're watching unfold be sort of a
manipulation of his design in some way
that's just kind of the impression that
i'm sort of getting and then with
trinity i feel like i'm pretty right
about it for what i was guessing in the
deja vu trailer because it became more
abundantly clear when neo eventually
becomes unplugged a big part of his
mission in the real world is to find
trinity herself and help unplug her help
save her because there was like that
footage in the last trailer they had her
design and she was all the matrix codes
and so i think jonathan groff is for
some reason with the seventh design of
the matrix he's using a former matrix to
have better control over it so he can
control it because agent smith he sought
control in the first movie the he wanted
to break out of the matrix he hated and
then ultimately he became the big
powerhouse villain so if they are doing
like a riff on agent smith i would
imagine that he's not just another guy
who's like i want out of here mr
anderson i think he's going to be a
character who is somehow using all this
to control the matrix himself yeah using
literally the past that we're all aware
of and perhaps even implanting it or
allowing it to exist within neo's
memories as
mr anderson's memories as a means of
further diluting what could be the truth
and leading him further away from
believing in that as the truth i am
fascinated by the little things with
that character too because you know like
they show the mouth melting moment on
him instead of somebody like neo and if
he's in the power position i'm like okay
is that a further like deception he is
playing forward towards neo or is there
something about that character that
maybe isn't uh an agent at first or
something like that i don't think he's
an agent i know i don't think he's an
agent smith i feel like he's kind of
embodying the role of that to kind of
mess with neo's mind a little bit or i
mean he might be i don't know
he seems like more than just a
resurrected agent smith is what i'm
getting at yeah
for sure something different in nature
but maybe having or ending up in a
similar place because i think
thematically you know like every matrix
movie has explored a different thing
that's probably someone calling me to
tell me about a matrix trailer dropping
because i think thematically you know
every matrix movie has explored
something different from this whole
philosophical religious spiritual
aspects identity choice uh capitalism
there's a whole lot of themes that just
keep piling on looking at the first
trailer seeming to hone in on therapy
and trauma this one especially seems to
be like the power comes from accepting
your past and not suppressing it which
is more of an emotion like i mean
emotional can be very subjective
especially when it comes to the trans
community of how they've really seen a
lot of themselves represented what i'm
getting at is that this a lot of the
powers it seems for neo at least in his
awakening is coming through with
accepting his past and not suppressing
it which i think is a good message for a
lot of people because a lot of us often
suppress our pain or suppress our trauma
and instead of you know dealing with it
the trauma is slowly overtaking us and
controlling our lives in ways we are
completely unaware of and that seems to
be kind of what's happening with neo
here in the first half of the movie is
that he's kind of just walking numbly
through life and then now he's slowly
rising back into his power and that
seems to be the theme for all the
characters so resurrection seems to also
be a play on acceptance yeah yeah and
and from what it looks like in that
first half they bring him in to almost
verify things they're they i forget what
the line is they're showing the mirror
scene and then they also have a mirror
set up for him to touch so it's like
using your past experiences your past
memories confronting them embracing them
and using them to help lead us forward
or something to that effect it made me
question
certain aspects of the editing here made
me question the real world the
harvesting fields and stuff like that
because a lot of that monologue that i
think it's jessica henwick says about
you know like the real world might not
even be or the nature of this might not
be as it seems i'm wondering if maybe
they're going to throw in another twist
of like what we thought was the real
world before it also isn't the real
world or something like that well
actually you know what i'm thinking
about too is that so much of the matrix
trilogy deals with destiny and choice
there's that that line in the first
matrix movie of he doesn't neo doesn't
believe in destiny because he doesn't
like the idea he's not in control of his
own future wondering if all these things
dealing with the past one version of the
protagonist is accepting his past so he
can have a control over the the outcome
of his future and then you got the
character like jonathan groff who's
using the past to control and i love
that thematically because you've heard
that you're not saying before don't let
the past control you
and so if you have like a physical
representation of that and actually come
to think about it uh with this being
called matrix resurrections and if this
is indeed dealing with you know like a
form of ptsd a big part of not
overcoming trauma in psychology is a
thing called recreation where we end up
recreating events from our past
especially when we don't overcome it so
i feel like that's also going to be an
element at play here and maybe that loop
line has something to do with it too i
don't know it's the whole thing about
the matrix it's all up to interpretation
oh that would be neat again then you
have jada pink and smith yeah who
returned iob you guessed in the real
world
everything just went to [ __ ] yeah
never got better in zion after the
little fake peace treaty they had i
guess
things can never be good in zion well i
mean there's so much to unpack and the
movie comes out very soon and i hope
people tune in for it in the actual
theaters not just on hbo max i feel like
it's going to have a bit of an uphill
battle just because it's week after
spider-man no way home at least in the
states i know like other parts of the
world this will probably do really well
but at least in the states you know it's
got a bit of an uphill battle i'm
excited man it's a freaking matrix let's
get it going let's get it going i
obviously love the hell out of this
franchise subscribe click that bell hit
that like button we'll catch you guys
soon
oh yeah the action looks great as always
[Music]